the intensity and suffering exacted by a
heartbreak
depends not only on the core fact that
we've been left
it also decisively depends on how
we've been left our hurt can be hugely
intensified
when we've been left badly just as it
may be rendered
a great deal more bearable when we're
fortunate enough
to have landed on a lover who has
learned the psychologically rich art
of mature breakups there are certain
things
guaranteed to make a breakup worse than
it ever needs to be
all decisions around relationships
should be taken with the awareness that
life is
desperately short for both parties it
therefore really shouldn't matter if the
holiday has already been booked
or if preparations for our birthday are
awkwardly
well underway as soon as the decision is
taken
a courageous lover will not dither out
of a misplaced desire not to upset
pre-existing plans they know they must
leave
they're ruining things of course but
they can see that the holiday or
restaurant meal
would in any case be doomed and they're
kind enough to know
not to waste any more of our precious
time
a wise departing lover knows not to
accuse the other
of more sins than they're guilty of it's
not they know
our fault that their career is going
wrong and we truly aren't responsible
for
their insomnia or the conflicts with
their brother the wise lover
keeps the list of accusations down to
the specific problems
that necessitated a breakup they don't
use the parting
as an occasion to rehearse all that
happens to be
a bit wrong with us inevitably far
longer
but here irrelevant charge sheet
[Music]
the most harmful lovers are those who
labor under a misplaced impression
that they need to be nice even when
they are firing us but there is in fact
no need for honeyed words
we simply require the basic information
and then
some privacy to put ourselves back
together again
indeed ongoing niceness simply confuses
us all the more
the tenderness makes us ache to restart
the relationship
for there seems no reason why not given
how they are behaving
clumsy lovers are so scared of the news
they have to share with us
they can't bear to come out with it and
therefore let it seep out
in odd symptomatic ways they start
drinking too much or
come home very late or advance odd
sounding theories about relationships
they hope through their strange and
harmful behavior to be fired
rather than to have to resign in sly and
unfair ways they seek to push us to take
the agonizing
next step on the other hand there is so
much that can spare us
excessive pain at the end kind
departing lovers make a sharp break once
they've decided they move swiftly to
letting us know
they clear off quickly they don't hold
out hints for reconciliation
they don't suggest that if we changed in
certain ways they'd reconsider
it's awful of course but there's a vein
of mature kindness in their brusque
manner
in an obviously difficult situation they
are sparing us
the extended torture of false hope
[Music]
good departing lovers try to explain in
convincing ways
why the relationship didn't work out
they might point out for instance
that you are both really quite anxious
by nature and therefore
struggle to soothe and calm each other
this isn't so much a complaint about you
as an observation about why the fit
between you as a couple
wasn't very helpful or they may explore
the ways in which the two of you
have powerfully divergent attitudes to
money and hence are set on a serious
collision course
they're not saying you're horrendous or
a fool just that the two of you
turn out not to be very adept partners
for each other
nice departing lovers let us see and
actively remind us
of what's not so nice or good about them
they admit that they brought a lot of
difficult things into the relationship
they admit perhaps that they are
obsessed by work they may acknowledge
that they're bossy or very controlling
they might be open about their
unfaithful nature they are doing us the
kindness
of showing us that life with them would
be seriously difficult in major ways
we're losing them but we're not losing
the prospect of a blissful
or problem-free future
good departing lovers know that the news
they're breaking
will inevitably lead to them being hated
for a time
they are brave in the face of this they
don't suffer
from the fateful and sentimental desire
to be loved
by people they no longer love
we're gradually disentangling two
distinct sources of pain
which mean very different things there's
the sorrow of losing someone we liked
but there may well also be the suffering
caused by the unfortunate ways
a lover acted at the end we may not be
able to escape the agony of broken
hearts
but we can always strive to keep it to a
very
basic minimum
our resilience cards are designed to
help us become tougher
in the face of adversity to learn more
follow the link on screen now
you